hey there's movies I just put up a speed
review and found out in the comments
section there's a new movie it's called
extraction they're gonna say it's been
on a roll with with the retro movies and
that's right I got to keep an eye on
those streaming services my bad
oversight on my part
anyhow let's talk about extraction
[Music]
so extraction stars Chris Hemsworth in
Bangladesh there was this high-profile
kid he's been kidnapped so Chris
Hemsworth he's a soldiers special ops it
seems pretty special to me I mean when
Thor's in the military it's special now
anyhow he goes in there to get the kid
and that's right
extract him and really I feel like this
is gonna be a short review cuz this is
what I gotta say about it if you are
here to see Chris Hemsworth kick a lot
of ass in John wick his way through a
bunch of nameless soldiers in the name
of getting this kid out of harm's way
hey I got the movie for you first I was
watching this movie I was like alright
so kid gets kidnapped and the soldier
has to get him how do these Avengers
people pick their other projects that
aren't Marvel do they just find the
script that sounds like the metric [ __ ]
Tilian number of other movies that are
just like it then the [ __ ] started going
down the firefights began and I was like
oh
this is damn entertaining it just was
man thank you John wick for making
action movies like this up there game
don't necessarily want every shooter
action movie to be like John wick
because when everyone's like John wick
when everyone's special that means no
one is however it's pretty entertained
to see Chris Hemsworth chew through
these soldiers damn I just love a good
hit in a movie like this well we have
some solid hits whether it's the bullets
people are taking whether it's Chris
Hemsworth taking a body and clubbing
someone else in their body with the body
this movie is an action movie that has
really entertaining action also this
movie's really violent gratuitous maybe
but also entertaining and I also
appreciate a movie that goes there when
a lot of other movies wouldn't like
there's just messed-up scene where
someone takes a kid and just Chuck's him
off a roof I was like oh okay what a lot
of movies do that no but it also
effectively Illustrated how shitty these
bad guys are also there's this one dude
hot on Hemsworth's tail looks likes guys
like The Terminator the action sequence
he was involved in was filmed to look
like it was one shot it was really
effective sometimes it was really smooth
sometimes it looked like the car scene
in War of the Worlds which looked
awesome when it first came out but it
hasn't aged so well you know see I'm
talking about right you know like put
him up and Dakota Fanning's all crying
in it you know that's it that's like you
say sometimes everything looked
perfectly real other times I was like
that is say chief I like there were
plenty of car wrecks and car crashes in
this movie where I was like that was
amazing then there was one in particular
I can think of I was like that was CGI
is [ __ ] I don't know if they ran out of
time or budget or has something to do
with the quarantine with like we can't
put the finishing touch with them
whatever look let's just put it out
possible like they can't finish this
season of The Walking Dead for that
reason so I guess that's postponed until
until I don't know some things in this
movie looked amazing other times you
could tell it's a GI doesn't change the
fact that when the guns are going down
we're just going on that metric solid
entertaining [ __ ] and that dude who
reminded me of the Terminator for a
large section of the movie it actually
has a really personal moment with him I
will say none of the side characters
really stand out this is the Chris
Hemsworth show I mean David harbors even
in the movie he's the one who stands out
the
most for the brief scene he's in but for
the most part is the Chris Hemsworth's
show it's the Chris Hemsworth show with
Chris Hemsworth kicking a lot of ass and
that John wick kind of way a couple
times it slows down I was like okay
we're burning daylight here if we can
get back to the bullets in the blood I
wouldn't hate that for the most part
anyway well there's the pretty touching
moment was Chris Hemsworth and that was
nice but you know what I mean for them
boots for bring on the bullet in the
slaughter that is to say that's what the
movie has going for it but that's what
the movie does really well so as I said
before earlier in this review I'll just
play the clip again if you are here to
see Chris Hemsworth kick a lot of ass in
John wick his way through a bunch of
nameless soldiers in the name of getting
this kid out of harm's way hey I got the
movie for you and that is simply that
long story short extraction was a pretty
damn good time no alcohol required
alright so extraction it's on Netflix
right now is supposedly should tell you
what streaming deserves it's on have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]